Will, you seem like a very ...
Your character's very emotional in the movies.
Yes.
He's very emotional, he's very in touch
with his emotions.
We're both very open.
Open with each other, you guys are more stoic, tougher.
A little dysfunctional.
Are you, you're an emotional guy in real life,
would you say?
At interesting moments, you know,
not necessarily the moments you would think.
I get emotional watching sports
(audience laughter)
and watching movies on commercial airline flights.
For some reason I feel very vulnerable.
(audience laughter)
In fact my wife and I were flying
and The Parent Trap was on.
(audience laughter)
Not the original, but Lindsay Lohan's Parent Trap
which ...
It's still great.
I am sobbing like a baby at the end.
And I know what's gonna happen.
[Andy] Yeah.
But I'm still, they got back together,
they got the parents together
and I have tears streaming down my face.
And my wife turns to me and is like what is wrong with you?
(audience laughter)
It's the Parent Trap.
(Conan laughs)
So that's an insight into my brain.
[Conan] Yeah.